[DISTINGUISHED MUSIC]
Hello.
Reboots are symptomatic
of a fundamental lack
of originality in Hollywood.
Have you no shame?
Here's your check for
the Animaniacs reboot,
you sellouts.
[CRASH]
[MUSIC - "ANIMANIACS" THEME]
(SINGING) It's time
for Animaniacs.
You should see
our new contracts.
All right guys, there's a lot
of pressure on our first lines.
Did we--
Wait-- don't!
Make sure it's good first.
[INHALE]
Maybe something reminiscent
of the first season?
[GROWL]
[BAM]
22 years later, and
I'm still a knockout.
[THUNDER]
I've tried online dating but
I keep getting catfished.
How do I know she's even real?
[BWAP]
[MUSIC]
This tablet contains the
sum of all human knowledge.
All human knowledge in one
easy to swallow tablet?
[GULP]
[CRASH]
[ELECTROCUTION]
Quantum mechanics,
quinoa wraps, Queen Bey.
We've missed so much.
[MUSIC - "ANIMANIACS" THEME]
Oh!
Sounds like an Odyssey.
My sandwich!
[FLY BUZZ]
[WHOOSH]
[LASERS BUZZ]
[BOINK]
Just where I left it.
[MUSIC - "ANIMANIACS" THEME]
Yakko, turn on the blacklight.
[CLICK]
[RAVE MUSIC]
Nothing unusual there.
[MUSIC - "ANIMANIACS" THEME]
Gee, Brain, what do
you want to do tonight?
The same thing we do
every night, Pinky.
Try to take over the wor--
[FOAM]
Wee!
Foam party!
[MUSIC]
[CHIMES]
I am the Pegasus.
I come bearing horrible
tidings of war from the--
[HONK]
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Less talk-y more flap-y.
[CHIMES]
Woo hoo!
[ZING]
[BOINGING]
[ZAP]
[CRASH]
[BOOM]
(SINGING) We're Animan-y,
totally insane-y,
Never mansplain-y.
Animaniacs!
Now the adoration pours in.
[DING]
[CHIME]
[BOING]
[BWAP]
Narf!
[MUSIC - "ANIMANIACS" THEME]